ومع تصاعد المخاوف من اطاله امد الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني تنام القلق بين الدول
المجاوره لروسيا ما دفع حلف شمال الاطلسي
الى محاوله تهدئه تلك البلدان وتضمينها
عبر زياده الدعم العسكري لها اتصيفعى
وزراء خارجيه الدول الاعضاء الى تهدئه
مخاوف تلك الدول المجاوره لروسيا التي
تخشى طبعا ان تزعزع موسكو استقرارها في ظل
استمرار الصراع في اوكرانيا الذي يؤثر على
امدادات الطاقه ويرفع الاسعار فيما تعاهد
ينزتون برج امين عام الحلف باجراء محادثه
مع مولدوفا وجورجيا والهرسك وهي الدول
التي تواجه ضغوطا من موسكو كما اكد ان
اعضاء الناتو سيتخذون المزيد من الخطوات
لمساعدتها على حمايه استقلالها وتعزيز
قدرتها على الدفاع عن ارضها مشيت علينا ان
مصلحه الاطلسي تكمن في ضمان سلامه
[موسيقى]